hello from the free state of florida
everybody i wanted to do a quick
check-in video uh first to let you know
that the show will start up again this
coming monday officially we're back in
business sorry for the delay
uh and then i wanted to just quickly
talk to you guys about the anniversary
of the january 6th the insurrection
as they call it uh because
you know i'm watching some of these news
clips and i listen to a little bit of
old joe biden today and kamala comparing
it to pearl harbor and 911
and it's just all so patently ridiculous
look if you violently
attack a u.s capital
or you violently attack private property
public property government property
whatever it is you have to be dealt with
right like you can't break the laws a
lot of these people were just expressing
their displeasure with the election they
were expressing their displeasure with
trust in the system and a lot of them
just walked in and peaceably
uh protested okay but there was some
violence and that needs to be dealt with
i think we can all agree on the basics
of that the real issue here is that a
year later
i don't think we have any more trust in
the system if anything we have far less
trust in the system and then when you
see politicians
like biden and kamala
and liz cheney using this for their own
political purposes just to basically
make it seem like if you don't agree
with them if you don't believe
everything that they believe
that you're a bad person that you're an
insurrectionist that you're violent that
the government should be looking at you
this is a problem this is a problem so i
would say
uh if you've got friends that are
freaking out about the one year
anniversary of january 6 you might want
to remind them
of the two years of violence that we've
had basically
from blm and antifa destroying portland
and seattle and new york city and san
francisco and the violence that was
instigated directly by people like
maxine waters and other democrats like
that's really what the issue is uh and
they're deflecting
from the violence that they're okay with
uh to project that everyone that
disagrees with them
is violent so in any event
today is january 6th
yesterday was january 5th
tomorrow is january 7th
everything's gonna be okay all right
we're back
in studio in a temporary studio but i
think you're gonna dig it we're back in
on monday
good luck everybody if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell